that's [ __ ] this one literally I'm
crying I have other stuff going on but
I'm crying hey what's going on everybody
from first we feast I'm Sean Evans
you're watching hot ones the show with
hot questions and even hotter wings and
today I'm joined by Carly Aquilino you
know from girl code you know her from
the stand up stage and now we're gonna
have some lunch
how you doing today I'm good I'm having
an anxiety attack about this how are you
with hot food I think I'm okay but I'm
really not sure this is that show I
special witness
yeah I'm questioning myself I don't even
know who I am ready to find out yes
you know sriracha right yes that's no
big deal yeah you were boots on the
ground for the 2015 VMAs but that one
was especially crazy it has a Nicki
Miley thing you had the Kanye speech
yeah we had the Bieber crying Bieber
crying on TV they didn't show all of him
crying like he was crying for a really
long time nobody saw yes it had bumped
from him to Miley and Miley started
recording but I guess he thought the
cameras were still on him or maybe he
was really just that emotional and was
hysterical crying for like five minutes
nobody knew what happened I was like did
you get a phone call while he was like
soaring through the air I think the next
morning the only thing we talked about
was Kanye I have decided in 2020 to run
for president I think he just threw that
president thing in because he was
bombing
yeah the first thing he said was like I
hate award shows everybody because we
didn't know where he was going then he's
like all right I'm running for president
buy and then everybody freaked out that
was the mic drop moment yeah you have to
tell me if I [ __ ] all over my face I'm a
good friend I'll let you know you travel
a lot and like me your twitter has sort
of become a vehicle by which you can go
to war with various airlines
yeah what's your biggest travel pet
peeve when something's gone wrong and
they don't tell you what it is and then
the people who work behind the counter
they're like all right unless you're
gonna walk home you're stuck here and
they know that
how about in-flight Go Go have you ever
used the Wi-Fi on a United flight 1.2
flight yes go go in play yeah I might
turn this show this meet this platform
that I have into just an excuse to go
after go yeah because to me that's a
criminal enterprise it is depending on
how long your flight is it cost so much
money and then it doesn't work oh the
first time I ever got it I was like you
know what I'm in a plane that's going 25
that's 25,000 feet in the air I'm going
600 miles per hour yeah yeah just kind
of curb my expectations when it comes to
Wi-Fi yeah then I get on JetBlue they
give you that [ __ ] he's gonna say Wi-Fi
in exactly round like my apartment
yeah and it's it's better than the Wi-Fi
have in my part
steal Wi-Fi from passenger no no from
like Pete other people that live near
babe yeah so it's actually better than
the Wi-Fi I have in my apartment the
government should honestly crackdown on
Coco and also people who walk around the
air put bare foot just like a little bit
more yeah I could take it though so MTV
Studios is in Times Square mm-hmm
complex for a couple blocks away
yeah but it's close enough to where
every once a while I have to go through
there and I get slammed in the chest
with mixtapes and then every yeah so
it's me I'm handling me aggressively
yeah what's the most annoying thing
about working in that area I live in
that area Wow nightmare what was I
thinking it's not even like I'm going to
work I have to deal with this it's like
oh I'm living my life this is my life I
think the worst is like the lady that
dresses up as Hello Kitty first of all
she doesn't even put her mask on she's
just the dress and the arms and she's
like give me a dollar
I'm like nobody wants to [ __ ] take it
you're horrifying
I saw the did you ever see the naked cow
lady probably 90 years old and walks
around with just tassels and underwear
and a guitar she doesn't play the guitar
and I've seen her get into fights with
people people like you're disgusting and
she's like no I'm high like I'm just
that's kind of my goal everybody
comments on this bottle in particular
cuz it's scary
cuz it looks like he's being stabbed it
really does look like chunk from the
Goonies who by the way is my lawyer
wait wanted to tell you he's a lawyer
and he's my lawyer it's real is he a
good lawyer he's the best does he like
being chunk from the Goonies or like
when you're like oh my god you're chunk
from the Goonies is he kind of go he
will talk about it but I bet you like
Pete if somebody came out it was like do
the truffle shuffle he would be like I
hope you know like I'm not doing I'm a
lawyer
girl code is interesting cuz I think
that you guys are kind of like surrogate
guidance counselors in a way for a lot
of the people who watch the show yeah
so I was gonna bounce some common role
code scenarios off of you and you can
just give me your take okay
best thing you can do to help a friend
get over a breakup
first of all lots of food is really
important
and don't push her to go out and meet
other guys cuz that's not if she's not
ready to do it it's just actually gonna
make her feel worse because I don't know
how many better options were actually
out there for her so you're a wing woman
your girlfriend she's talking to a guy
but kind of giving you the look like I
want to hit the eject button on this
conversation if you ever want a guy to
stop talking to a girl she just has to
be like I like you a lot and then he'll
be like I'm [ __ ] guys let's say you
sleep with someone who's mega famous
right okay and then they fall asleep
let's go
like oh so I can picture it Johnny Depp
okay Bieber or Dre okay okay and then
they fall asleep and then you see this
every once in a while or somebody will
take this selfie but they'll have other
their face with the person sleeping
behind that how big a violation is that
that's so shady right like also it
doesn't make you look good
no it at all it makes you look terrible
I hate oh boy let me see no brain can't
answer the question that you're good
you're good you're good okay you look
good
if you do that to James Harden or
whatever that doesn't make James Harden
look bad yes it makes him look fine like
expect it it's expected of people to be
hooking up with each other but then it
makes you like why are you so thirsty
okay so this next one is actually our
hot sauce it's the hot one's hot so hey
I'm the hot one show okay you're doing
amazing though a lot of people get
through the first floor no problem you
start getting two six seven eight but
this one's tasty so let's enjoy this guy
right mm-hmm so you like it's kind of
sweet with the pineapples is something
gonna happen I think you're in the clear
we didn't set out to make a really hot
sauce it's just a taste it is hot it is
hotter than this one this is in perfect
order you're friends with Charlemagne
and Charlemagne to me is such an
interesting person because he has like
90 jobs he is a hot take on everything
what do you think is something that
people would be surprised to learn about
char
all right he's gonna probably hate me
Charlene doesn't for it in his own pants
what does that mean like he takes his
pants off too far that is a weird plate
or his underwear and his underwear so he
asked her fart in like open air yeah cuz
he thinks it's gonna make everything
dirty I would want to date somebody that
doesn't want to fart like in his own bed
in his own pants cuz that's like always
an issue when you're in a relationship
like a certain amount of times like is
there no magic anymore
that would be the perfect person to be
with the romance is never gonna dive in
Charlotte exactly now the game is
changing so this is where we go from
pros nope no booger no Flutie's Wow okay
no sauce killing it okay we are killing
it
you have a dog Whoopi Goldberg she's one
of these dogs that has an Instagram
following all her own judging by her
feet it seems that she watches a lot of
TV with you
I had to one of my friends has her now
cuz I was going on the road and she was
getting sick because she's a French
Bulldog and their faces are like smushed
in their faces are like smushed and her
face is like smushed into her head I'm
dying you're holding together pretty
good I'm a quivering eyes but maybe it
was a whoopee but uh you guys watch on
TV but sorts of things do you what do
you wonder what I watch on TV no
literally friends that's it once I'm
done with the last episode I started it
back who's your favorite character
Phoebe Phoebe I knew you're gonna say Oh
Phoebe hi cuz I would think that you and
Phoebe are kind of like kindred spirits
in a way it's the nicest thing anybody's
ever said to me
this just gave me a urinary tract
infection that's how hot it is
which of your tattoos would you say is
your favorite this one can you see it
it's the number three it's a number
three me and my two brothers have it
there's three of us that's why it's two
three and my brother gave me this tattoo
my brother oh but that's [ __ ] this
one literally I'm crying I have other
stuff going on but I'm crying but you
have a tattoo would that you would say
is your least favorite oh yeah - when I
was 13 years old it says life is
beautiful and Italian hashtag Long
Island Princess is what that was but I
was like 13 and my brother told me to
get a tattoo and it's like the worst
literally I don't even know if the guy
worked at the tattoo shop he had to have
been sort of under the table or off the
radar anyway to give a thirteen-year-old
the test yeah well I had a fake ID that
said I was 32 this little lady if she
like gave me her ID and she must have
been like blacked out when she took her
driver's license picture cuz she was
literally like this so I was like
getting tattoos going to bars and
whenever I got ID'd I was like but you
would walk up to the bar with the same
just be like they really just let her in
what happened in your life I think it's
just by this show I think it's wedding
eye boogers so I think maybe by being
hyperstimulated that I am now dead my
mouth yeah inside how about when it
comes to heckling and stand-up do you
think that the female stand-ups are
heckled in a way that's different from
male stand-ups or is it all more yeah
cuz guys stand-ups don't go on stage and
people are like you have a nice dick
like nobody says that to them but girls
will go be like hey nice ass like it's
depending on how drunk they are you will
get like the most vulgar things like
Instagram comments like you're not even
real exact that's what I tell myself do
you read them all the time you do I'm
obsessed I don't really care if somebody
makes fun of me or whatever who cares
you know yeah but I always get pissed
and they say for example that the wings
are fake and that they're not that hot
and that this is all just a sham that
drives me nuts Carly does it drive you
nuts this is the most real thing I've
ever eaten thanks so anybody that's
saying that the wings are fake get out
of here get out and stay out what about
for you is there like a thing that comes
up that you're like people bring up my
ex-boyfriends people bring up like a
lady what are you doing like why did you
guys break up what what about this
person I'm like why I don't worry but I
don't need to explain it hi everybody
get off Carly's nuts all right about a
dating history yeah your business yeah I
mean you could still like don't like
unfollow me though like as long as you
follow me like it's [ __ ]
at first we feast we do pay attention to
how people snack so I know that you like
crusty bowls and I know that you like
Cinnabon right those are great snacks
but it's kind of prepubescent yeah taste
I mean let's that's a little is it
though you have a kitty taste all right
yes I like peanut butter and jelly I
like cinnamon buns
I like everything though you like fries
I really like rising it fries twice
yesterday have you ever had fries twice
in one day from two different places not
from two different places but don't set
up my lab nicely into this next question
all right this way so I have you are
it's gonna hit four of the most iconic
okay rise fast food fries I want you to
react to them I want you to rank them
let me know what you think so this first
one we got McDonald's McDonald's is like
nostalgic purposes only for me like I'm
eating McDonald's I'm like this isn't
real they're number one I'm like
everyone's lives I think overrated then
if everybody thinks they're number one
then everybody you know how about these
you ever in the airport go to
chick-fil-a and get the waffle fries
waffle fries might be my favorite okay
do you have KFC fries in there no but
all right well then waffle fries in my
favorite when do you surprised they're
more visible
yeah they shouldn't have changed them
though they changed them yeah now
they're quality natural cut fries with
sea salt
it's our recipe I liked them before they
were at quality I like them when they
were [ __ ] have you ever had these the
curly Arby's fries I feel like you like
Arby's this isn't gonna work out I think
it's okay
I think it's okay can you rank them
chick-fil-a number one number one can I
just do curly fries since our Arby's
I've never actually like I don't I don't
have with Arby's curly fries are number
two then McDonald's then what is Wow
by the way this did not affect me that's
amazing I don't think it did so this one
you can't escape because it's tradition
around here - dad the last wing
this is Megadeth sauce with liquid rage
it is our hottest hot sauce and you got
to be careful on the dab too because
there are times when get a little cocky
careful Carly yes I'll do it
I'm gonna hold it I don't want to be
responsible for putting too much on I'm
more nervous
you're like my MA I am a kindergarten
okay so last question Cheers I'm gonna
kill myself
you'll not
I just followed it thoughts it's [ __ ]
terrible who's your biggest celebrity is
it the rod I knew it was the rock I knew
it was the rock tell me why you like the
rock once you once you swallow it is
when it really gets aggressive it is the
worst why would anybody put that on eggs
or so why would anybody make it okay I
like the wrath because he's the first
person I ever had a crush on when I was
young
cuz I just watch WWF and I mean look at
him he's the type of guy that like can
just carry me around he tweets me back a
couple times he's tweeting me back about
this has been going on a segment we've
been going back and forth for years
years why did you do it that to me to
meet to make it through that's why all
we did is we wanted to draw attention to
Carly cause Carly's a busy girl with a
lot going on and she made it through and
it was such an impressive run and now
Carly the floor is you only let people
know what you got going on in your life
I don't even know okay guy code versus
girl code comes out on the 28th of June
which is this month so check it out
follow me on Instagram don't Yami
you